I kept getting tweets from you guys on
Twitter Justine where's your video
talking about the new iPad pro and the
new MacBook Air I have just been so
conflicted on what videos to make
recently and I talk to a lot of you guys
on Twitter and you said you want us to
keep continuing to make content so here
I am making your video talking about the
new iPad and it's really hard to get
excited about tech when people's lives
are being completely just destroyed and
you know you guys keep telling us as
creators to keep creating for
entertainment value I've made some
videos talking about my thoughts and my
feelings so I don't want to keep
bringing it up so let's just jump in to
talking about the new iPad pro and the
new MacBook Air and they even updated
the Mac Mini they've got some new Apple
watch bands out as a out of everything
I'm most excited about the new iPad pro
and the new keyboard that they came out
with so here it is this is the new iPad
pro and first of all looking at this
photo I'm just love this because this is
the new keyboard also has a trackpad so
you guys can also see right here this is
a USBC pass through so this will also
charge your iPad while it's dropped
instead of having to plug it into your
iPad and have like a crazy cable hanging
out this also allows for the USB C port
to be open on the iPad so you could
transfer photos or basically whatever
else you might need to plug in to that
whether you have like an external camera
we have a thermal camera plugged in if
you guys know a video that I made about
thermal imaging on your iPhone it's
pretty awesome you guys should
definitely check it out cuz it's great
because you can have the freedom of
moving your iPad around to 130 degrees
so it has an 8 core GPU a core CPU it
also has an enhanced thermal design and
this is the highest performance on an
iPad ever obviously you would have to
imagine so because they're not gonna
make an iPad that's not as good as the
last one
the graphics are actually 2.6 times
faster than the previous gen they've
also updated the camera so now there's a
wide-angle camera on the iPad and it
also has lidar support lidar stands for
light detection and ranging
so this sensor is measuring the amount
of time that it takes for light to
reflect off of an object not only is
this gonna be huge for playing augmented
reality games but being able
caPSURE a 3d image of a space I'm sure
you've all seen the IKEA app where you
could just drop in furniture I mean
that's gonna be basically the new normal
of being able to shop for furniture like
you 3d scan your environment
see if said thing looks good in said
environment click purchase and that's it
it arrives at your house
also to be really cool for gaming so I
can't wait to see some more games take
advantage of AR it is always kind of
crazy trying to play AR games with the
iPad because it is kind of a large
device so when you're kind of just like
running around getting crazy make sure
you have a good grip on that thing is
you don't want to be dropping it and you
guys know me I am I I can't be trusted
it's crazy that they are able to bring
this technology into an iPad like
something so small like this is stuff
that they've been using you know at NASA
like Apple even says on their website
it's being used for the next Mars
landing now I've got light on my iPad
I'm ready to go to space honestly I'm
ready to go to space so let's just sign
me up I don't know I mean what's it like
up there I mean it can't be any worse
than what's happening here this is able
to measure reflected light both indoors
and outdoors up to 5 meters away I'm
definitely excited to check this out as
soon as I get my hands on one of these
and then I'm gonna work on booking the
first flight on that Mars mission who's
gonna say no to my application oh um I
just think oh you're lighter okay cool
come on come on aboard have a seat
as far as the processor it has an 8
holes II Bionic chip and I have been
editing a lot on my iPhone like I've
been editing way more than I ever have
before I've been using luma fusion it's
an iOS editing app it works on your
iPhone and on your iPad I'm very excited
to use this on the iPad I've only used
it very briefly since as many of you
know I'm obsessed with tick-tock and I I
know a lot of you guys locked that video
and you weren't really concerned about
me that video was honestly not too far
from the truth it obviously was a little
bit dramatic so I do plan on doing some
more editing on this now that I've been
using that app a lot more I can't wait
to try it on the iPad and if you guys
are looking to start editing on
we'll check out luma fusion it is a paid
app but I cannot say enough great things
about it
the new magic keyboard like this thing
looks really great so like I said it
does have a USB C port for pass-through
charging and since it does have trackpad
support you can use a Magic Mouse you
can also use one of the magic track they
call the Magic Trackpad it's a call the
magic know what is it like the regular
trackpad because of like the iMac it's a
called a Magic Trackpad yeah okay it
just called the Magic Trackpad well what
do you know so here's a little
demonstration of what the cursor looks
like when you use the trackpad James
Rath actually brought this to my
attention that this was something that
was huge in the accessibility community
so it's really cool to sort of see where
that started and now it's kind of a
mainstream feature on the iPad for the
trackpad so it looks like it weighs over
a pound all day battery life
connectivity they do obviously have a
Wi-Fi and an LTE version I can use a R
to see the new iPad okay why didn't you
say so there it is look how good that's
gonna look like can you looks big Wow
okay okay for a few seconds convinced
myself the iPad was actually here so
there it is that's what it would look
like sitting at my desk let's get a real
good close-up look at this look at that
keyboard all the top looks tonight is
very close to me can we see so there's
the the charging port is over here get
up there real close see that you see it
there it is this is weird this is so
crazy the iPad is right here making it
smaller hmm a little look a little baby
okay I'm enjoying this way too much so
it comes in two models that is the 11
inch which starts at $7.99 and the
twelve point nine inch surfs at $9.99
they also announced an upgrade to the
MacBook Airs I think one of the most
exciting things I think for a lot of
people that didn't like the previous gen
keyboards is they do have the new
keyboard that is the same keyboard as
they put on the 16 inch MacBook Pros
which I still can't believe there's a 16
inch MacBook Pro
my old MacBook the other day just to get
a bunch of files off of it I was like oh
wow it's significantly smaller I
couldn't believe the difference after
using this one for the past several
months see here's the new MacBook Air
looks very much like the previous
version has a starting price at $9.99
they also have an educational discount
obviously on almost all things Apple so
you are a student definitely look into
that it's got the Retina display a new
magic keyboard of course
touch ID twice the performance faster
graphics and also double the storage
capacity up to a four core Intel Core i7
processor you can expand the storage up
to 2 terabytes the graphics performance
is up to 80% faster which is a pretty
significant update especially if you're
doing video a lot of people complain so
much about the arrow keys so they did
change that back to the previous version
and the same arrow keys as the new 16
inch MacBook Pro I really did get used
to this keyboard I did not at all mind
the previous gen butterfly keyboard
mechanic I actually really liked it so
switching over to this again it took a
little getting used to but now that I'm
used to it I don't even remember what it
was like back in the butterfly keyboard
days they also increased the size the
trackpad which is really nice because
being so used to having the MacBook Pro
that larger trackpad it is so convenient
it's also got touch ID and it has the t2
security chip I love having touch ID on
my computer I'm really looking forward
to the day that they do finally
integrate face IDs into the the
front-facing cameras which I feel like
is something that I'm surprised they
actually haven't done yet I wonder what
the reason is price security I'm not
sure I mean they already have the
technology so I think it's just a matter
of time before that is also integrated
into the computer but I love having
touch ID on my laptop I love it so much
they also announced some new Apple watch
bands and some new phone cases I love
when they do kind of like the spring
update of colors I love that this watch
band so much I've been rocking this one
for a while it's the Nike sport pink one
I guess last but not least they also did
an update to the Mac Mini Mac Mini is
just it's such a cute machine and I
think for a lot of people if you already
have a monitor and you want a very small
little computer
I mean this is it's great now has up to
60% faster until it gonna create
graphics five times faster system
performance you can upgrade it to a six
core i5 or i7 processor and of course
storage is also always a struggle I feel
like on machines especially solid-state
so this one you could expand up to two
terabytes load up to four times faster
read speeds I look forward to getting a
chance to check out some of these things
and doing you some reviews for you guys
let me know if there's any other thing
that you would like to know about them
and when I get it hopefully I can test
it out look you guys so much for
watching I know this is a really crazy
time to be talking about tech but I
think one of the most important things
again I will keep reiterating this is be
kind ask your friends how they're doing
ask them if they need anything ask them
if their friends or family needs
anything and most importantly keep
yourself healthy
wash your hands stay inside as much as
possible practice social distancing I'd
love to also hear in the comments what
you guys are doing to occupy your time
and if you're watching any new shows oh
my god anybody watch HBO the west-world
premiere I think it might be my most
favorite thing that I've ever seen ever
absolutely ever the fact that they know
I don't wanna spoil it I'm not gonna say
anything I'm not gonna say anything at
all oh no I'm done I'm done it was so
good if you haven't watched it you guys
better go watch two seasons catch up
because he's in three premiere oh my god
Aaron Paul it was just everything about
it I'm done I'm done why
you
[Music]